son las justas que abren el ciclo
olímpico de parís 2024 en la región y
ella comenzó la actividad en esta ciudad
al norte de colombia lo hizo de la mano
de la esgrima concretamente con el
florete masculino individual y la espada
individual femenina de triunfos para el
peruano lucas nicolás lúcar y para la
colombiana maría jaramillo también hubo
precios de plata para venezuela y perú y
bronces para chile colombia paraguay y
venezuela y sobre el terreno nuestro
enviado especial luis méndez entrevistó
al campeón olímpico de venezuela rubén
limardo quien nos entregó sus
sensaciones sobre esta competición para
nosotros la expectativas siempre buscar
siempre el oro siempre el podio siempre
estará ahí entre los mejores
obviamente que tenemos un contrincante
muy fuerte como colombia nosotros
venimos el panamericano hace como 13
días aproximadamente en paraguay de
vencer a la colombiana final por un
toque de muerte súbita ya fue muy
cerrado siempre ha sido cerrado no y
bueno en esta oportunidad yo tiene unos
atletas que se han estado preparando en
francia
y he hecho un trabajo bastante bastante
fuerte con ellos